hello hello to all so a
quick introduction in fact
welcome so on this leader the
circle
it's an experience in fact that we
initiated at the beginning of the year in the
first google cloud this myth the idea
go one way in fact c  is really to
bring together a panel of leaders from all
walks of life, from start-ups to
large companies across all
the different industries that may
exist to focus
on themes that are
particularly dear to you.  we are going to talk
about a few tricks not the technologies
obviously but I think we will
also talk above all about use cases
we will also talk about the important subjects
which come up almost systematically
in all the evaluations that we can
do with the  big companies in
europe in france the wheels that they
are positioned gold we can talk about
conspiracy we are going to talk about privacy we are going to
talk about security it is very important
we are going to talk about intelligence  artificial intelligence
we are going to talk about machine learning
we are trying to see how this
technology can allow you
I heard big and big
words this morning like survival to survive
but finally I attach
more importance to opportunities especially
than  we can tell you that we can build
with its technologies so we are
really going to focus on this
opportunity aspect in what in fact we can
help you to change the way of
working but above all to innovate
once again ea to build as they say
what's  next what is
important for the future in order to
obviously be able to increase your
position on your respective markets to markets
so I wanted to renew once again
so our welcome and
above all to come back to the objective of this
this afternoon we are innovating  a bit and we
are also fond of feedback at the end
of the session so
we have to at home I think it's
something that has been very well received so
far
do  nc also do not hesitate to send us
your comments and without further
delay I will pass the floor to
bastien and grégoire who are our
managers in france and who will give a
further overview of our
activity welcome gentlemen thank you hello to
everyone and welcome thank you for
staying with them this morning is what we're
going through the gendarmerie asks for a good view I
'm going to accompany you in any case
all morning and then the beginning of
the afternoon to deal with a certain
number of subjects  we are going to talk as
Sébastien said about our solutions and we are
above all going to listen to the testimony of a
salon of our customers as you have
heard paquin
high big data machine learning the
computing power available thanks to the
clash ange our business
these  transformations they are critical
for most of you and google
is at the heart of these transformations
so what is important for us
today is to show you what
that means concretely  ment and that we
can look at a certain number of
important subjects, in particular on the
infrastructure dimension google
today cloud it is an
investment which is strategic for
the google company
in general we innovate in a very
important way during the last year
it's more than 500 product releases that
we have launched on our google
cloud platform suite and on our
jesuit suite also we are investing
massively in the infrastructure that
you could see this morning the
emblematic figure that sebastien shared 30
billion  investment over the
last three years
I think it's important to ask yourself
to fully understand what that means
and so we're going to talk
about it later and then the third subject is
safety which is obviously at the heart  from
our concerns to the heart of your
concerns and so we have
a half-hour session just after us
to present to you what that means in
concrete terms p  our us
in france we live we
currently think a very
interesting momentum on the public cloud
the business customers that we
support we see them we were starting
an experience center on
the infrastructure of the dimensions of
liftactiv li chn/n figures
essentially and there  we are currently seeing
really interesting reflections
around a
very critical and very
disruptive second wave of compensation around the public cloud and
so for that, well, google cloud is
quite strongly developed today we are around
a hundred people
present at  paris to support our
large customers of our large
corporate customers in their transformations
in the use of our solutions and
therefore it is technical pre-sales sales roles
of toxin animation managers our
ecosystem of partners the next
host of  service professionals
so all this to support our
customers in their development, their
transformation and their s  success so we
are delighted to have testimonials
that were made to you earlier
during the keynote
we are lucky to have with us
thomas from dailymotion christophe from
amadeus and françois de la redoubt who
will be back  time to go into
a little more detail about their
experience the issues they managed
to address thanks to the total challenges
they also had to address to
have their solutions adopted
and then for a moment to  pause google
cloud platform today these trials
we mentioned it for two hours in
ours acquis but I like this figure it's
a billion chili dressings served
every day we are challengers but we have
an installed base which  is still
quite significant and then it's a
set of big names that you can
see behind me but the
emblematic customers thought that they who are
at the start of the distribution I was
telling you about earlier people  s like
hsbc airbus and where spotify
the second important point that I
wanted to share with you is on our
ecosystem of partners so bas
sebastian mentioned this morning also
which does not take away we have
developed it a lot and especially in france
so we are working  obviously today
with an ecosystem of partners
laugh on service partners
therefore globo the system integrators dsn and
then companies more specialized
in consulting for example in the management
of change linked to
collaborative solutions people specialized in
the run of the  bild cloud outsourcing
machine learning big data
we are lucky to have a
number of them with us today this morning
present in the room
or just behind on the stands who
are who are on the left when you
leave  the room therefore the accenture claranet
sopra devoteam be done in particular and
our ecosystem obviously this does
not limit no man's where our
service partner but it  includes all of the
tech companies
we work with that we
have we've created
partnerships gateways connections so that
's really critical for us and we
've announced a lot of things since the
start of the year we're working on
a lot  with intel with escape from
pivotal tennis bastien will come back to this
subject and we will do later in
the afternoon before a double live on
this hybrid cloud dimension in particular
thank you grégoire and you call it's not
only the platform it's  is also
Jesuit all the collaborative part
you have here more than 30 launches that
we announced this year so I'm not going to
do them all but I have a few
like dlp for drive like steam drive
like istream drive like I like  board
and it's full of others are coming at the end
of the year and anna in my team at 12:10 p.m.
in room 3 will talk about it
so here I mentioned a very
important subject we still have hundreds
of engineers who work on it
full of launch I want to
thank everyone all of its customers
many of you have your
business the taste of business here
thank you for having renewed your confidence
and deploying your uses last
message it will be you  go see three
times today I'm sorry
I insist it's not very pretty it's
me who makes them but hey we talk a lot
in cinema about big data and machine learning
we differentiate ourselves on that we are
pioneers on the subject  we have or as
you know we are behind hadoop and its
hosts ensor flou which is
becoming a standard on match in
learning
but we must not forget that there is all
that we admire and 15 thousand
engineers on it  on the infrastructure and that these
are real subjects also the
hpc storage and I spoke about it for
half an hour earlier on the subject
of the hybrid cloud
how you can have workloads
at your place and at our place so here it is  is
a v  rai subject i want you to understand when you go
out tonight that this
new platform is both it's not
that the chan nicklas of big data machine
is also made of loose infrastructures
pc subjects as well real well down
to earth  earth and we have a lot of things we have a
great network of great machines and
I hope 4 4 and a half hours I would
have convinced you very well so thank you I wil
pass the floor to julie
blanchet in our teams who a
e talking about safety  and complexes
thank you applaud him thank you bastien
hello to all my name is julien
blanchez as my accent may betray me
I warn you that I am Belgian I have been
working for more or less ten years
at google
the last five years in
collaboration with the teams
security and compliance engineering for
the last few years in the united states I
just returned about ten months ago
I am based in Brussels and my role
consists of engaging with the
highly regulated companies of his passions tr
Regulated companies and
the regulators directly either the
European financial or health regulators
and therefore I will typically be one of the
people who will engage with your
teams
when it comes to
answering your security questions in a granular way
your plans  'security assurance or
facilitate exchanges with
regulators
if this kind of communication is
necessary I have a lot of content I have
a bad tendency to use
Franglais from time to time so if I
start speaking like Jean Claude  van
damme you excuse me I hope the
comparison stops there it seems it
seems at the end here are millions
of organizations today here not
all organizations today
are considering moving
all or part  of their cloud workloads
you're going to hear throughout the
day different reasons
why they have this interest which
is more surprising to many
of you  us but I also think
for us as we were
relatively surprised at the interest of the
subject a few months ago is that
security has become one of the reasons
why many of these
companies are now looking to the cloud
as an option probably
necessary it is my job to validate
to prove this security with your
teams with your decision makers
with your risk manager lawyers some
analysts today
industry observers are united around
this common opinion that the
public cloud  today is able
to offer security conditions that are
going to be very difficult
for you to achieve in any case with reasonable efforts
given that this is not your
core business in the next 35
minutes I will  try to summarize for you
why we are in this
situation of strength really to better
protect the give
it is this discussion that
[Music]
I can have  or my colleagues can
have with your teams can last
half a day a few weeks or even a
few months
the lists of questionnaires can
vary from 100 ha
I believe that the record today is
a major telecom operator who
offered us six hundred and fifty questions to
answer
please don't try to break the record
the answer is always
the same during these
exercise validations we manage to demonstrate that
the security systems in place
meet or exceed expectations
or what you are able to  put
in place today,
on the other hand, the feeling is always
also invariably the same the
moment when your security
teams your legal teams your risk managers
realize that to benefit from
this security
they must take data and
port it to a third-party infrastructure
that you apparently have
less control over that's a matter of
trust
maybe  how our grandparents
felt when they had to put all
their savings in the bank
I remember my parents being hesitant about whether
or not to use credit cards at
the time it's almost a
leap of faith  for some in
some companies i see that it is
necessary to take i
realized that there is no way you
in the security discussion we can
you find it you demonstrate it the
trust discussion is much
more  complex
we cannot impose trust on you
all we can do is
be more transparent provide you with
contractual commitments prove to you
that we are meeting the expectations of the
regulator
and then continue the communication that is
the second part of what I  will
try to summarize in the next 35
this process you are not the only ones
of course to engage in it all
cloud customers regardless of
vendor go through 7.7 this moment of
decision  s with regard to google
cloud
we are talking about 6 million organizations
today that use
google services 1 3 million benefit from them for
free these are
educational organizations or NGOs 3 million are
private organizations so they
pay fees  licenses to use them i am
showing some of these slides because
you recognize organizations that
deal with the
most sensitive information
an organization like pwc which has over
two hundred thousand employees dealing with
tax funds tax
forms  tax of their clients
organizations like the economist whose
life or death of sources may
depend on the security that can
be brought to it
I do not have the
marketing rights of this subject the  name but a
French daily
at least equivalent to the qualities of
an economist is also part of our
references from companies closer to
us which we are very proud to be
able to protect.  manage the data
and perhaps to name here a
specific example of the ability to manage a
lot of data in great security
the American regulator who asked
the son company to carry out an audit a
consolidated and real consolidated audit trail
of all transactions
American stock markets in
real time 25 billion dirhams event per
hour which are stored on google cloud
and which are used by regulators to
keep track of all
transactions to be able to
identify flash crashes the
causes of flash crashes or other
illicit transaction trends
there is a name that i still want to
mention for which it is also
not communication rights but
as they blogged a year ago
also about it i encourage you to
search on whatever search engine
suits you  i'm actually saying that i
shouldn't be making this joke don't know
i urge you to look for theresa may
cabinet office j suit de  then for more than a
year and a half theresa may's office practice has been
using j suite to collaborate
just to give you an idea of the techn
cal and contractual guarantees that
e are able to give your
eams today to opera
e then to enter  in
the nitty-gritty and summarized the
technical reasons the can be summarized in six
major trends why a
public cloud provider today
is able to secure your data
as well the first theme to have
with anticipation
when one wants to estimate the
security capacity of a system there is a
very well-known framework which consists in
anticipating estimate the capacity
of anticipation estimated the capacity of
defense estimated the capacity of
reaction okay that diagram very well known if you
work in security in terms
of anticipation  global cloud platforms
have an incomparable advantage
google specifically you
may already be familiar with this
transparent operates this dish  eforms
over a billion users
I believe that google photo has just
passed the billion users as
well so we could add them
to this list
if we reflect on what has been the core
business of google for 20 years c  is to
make a near real-time copy of the internet
for certain sites to
take that copy and index it under
our computing centers and provide you with
search results in
milliseconds
what does that mean all that
is fantastic on the web we
know it and we share it with you
everything terrible on the web a
large part of it we know
it we also share it with you this
information is not kept
proprietary it is packaged in
a service called ses bras or zing very well
known to all browser manufacturers if
you use safari mozilla opera
today you are also protected
by the information of ses bras or
easing which warns you when
you are going to enter an illicit site
that you are going to do the last the
last step at your own risk and peril
and that it is further the site is with
bad intentions
in general I scan the room to
check if someone is doing like that  of
the head so i know this person
and she is on a site like this
recently but no one has done ok a
service of the same style less well known
these little
android net it's 2 billion devices
today hundreds  millions
of devices are surveyed every day to
trace the security information of the
devices and allow us to build
an almost
real-time map of the evolution of malware, which
allows us to often anticipate
developments or in any case to respond
very quickly when crises
emerge you could say these are
trends these are very consumer indications
I have a
banking platform I have a platform that
requires more guarantees  s google appeals
to more than a billion users is
one of the world's largest flame
payment platform fully
certified gmail serves more than a
billion users including tens of
thousands of hospital doctors who
deal with  personal
health information and therefore had to pass
certifications
relating to this sector for a
long time so the ability
to anticipate a very
important advantage for all
google cloud platforms in particular the second
theme is the management of complexity
and how the  complexity to manage when
the infrastructure teams
started building our infrastructure 20
years ago they had the unique luxury
of starting from scratch
and not having to manage the layers of
complexity that today are
probably a  of the main causes
of the cause beyond the security problem
that we have we have online
today that does not mean that
google is not  complex a google
is 2 billion lines of code
thirty thousand engineers have between twenty
and thirty thousand engineers who
interact every day on 2
billion 2 billion lines of code
something like 40 thousand yes what
this modification per day on the code
or  in any case on the soul
infrastructures
it is an immense complexity which is
managed by the automation of
the intelligent automation not
to reuse the word of machines
yellow line which allows us to manage this
complexity which also allows us to
solve  a lot of
security issues by the way if you want
a concrete example when you've
convinced yourself convinced
your thinking of spamming
i think in the room we
all used email in the
90s we remember how the end of the
90s spam was going to kill e-mail
another solution had to be found
e-mail had become unmanageable
if you use gmail today  you
have less than 0.1 percent spam in
your inbox the reason why that
and it's because these machines have
become very good at identifying what's relevant
what's windy what
's dangerous isn't  dangerous and
when we know that spam is one of
the primary vectors of the first
malware distribution vectors it's an
important victory which in my opinion we do
n't celebrate enough you want to project
this into the future the big problem of
online security  today it
's authentication deplorable hygiene
because we all have it would be
so much more secure if we could
do without passwords
we already published two years ago
research results which show
that by making a
intelligent interpretation of the signals we
share with our devices whether
it shows whether our phones
the way I type the
way the sound the voice
what I look like putting in
c  orrelation these signals we can
identify you by a factor of more or
less ten thousand times more
precise than
an average size password once we identify as
well we can authenticate you
automatically it is exactly under
the services to which you  have access
so in summary we can imagine a
world where as long as I have this phone I
will use it access to all the
corporate services of google when I
pass this device to my son the
access permissions fall to pokemon
beautiful
that's the reality well so
that's that kind of security you
get you get when
you're a cloud customer automatically
these are benefits you
don't have to do
additional roll out projects for new
technologies those things  become out
of the box security by default asks
the regulator that's what you have the
third of the four that's
the overall infrastructure probably the
most i  mportant competitive advantage of
google a global infrastructure 17
computing centers spread around the
world mainly connected by a
proprietary dark fiber network which
allows us to have a very
significant advantage when it comes to offering
a collaboration platform to
the  planetary scale the smallest
milliseconds of delay in
the interaction of documents can make it
useful or completely
annoying to use a collaborative coop program
but we talk about it less
often in terms of security
gives us a significant advantage but
many  more in control of our
destiny
when it comes to transferring
information from one part of the world to
the other part of the world we must -
otherwise not rely on
third party providers third party telecom providers who
are subject to their own
regulatory constraints in their country
we are much more in control of
our destiny on this platform you
can  You obviously decided to use it
to break down your data
globally or localize data in
the case of google cloud platform you
can actually locate
data in certain places in
certain regions depending on your
technical or even
regulatory preferences if you think  that you
have but we will come back
throughout this presentation on
the interest of doing it or
not and how you should in our opinion
think about this kind of decision
this platform is also the
platform which allows us to deliver
a service  which aims and I will use a
few words of jargon which aims at a
level of service of 0-0 point of
recovery point objective sorry their
body does not burn a target of zero the
manufacturer and objective is the amount
of data that we estimate to lose we
estimate  riom lose in the event of a
major disaster due to the
real-time replication of data through this
network
our  e ricort meets the objectives and 2 0
our recovery time objective and 2 0
also
instant failover reminder and in fact this
platform is subjected every year
to simulations of major disasters on
a planetary scale where we
successively extinguish a region of the world
a second region of the world  the
engineers' joke is that when three
regions of the world have no power
you had other things to do than
check your emails but the reality
is that the reality is that you
as a user of  google
you have never perceived these exercises
and yet they take place every year and
its disaster exercises
[ __ ]
the third message out of seven this
very important transparency and which is
also a workhorse of the
security teams of google knows  that it is a
platform that allows us to promise
an equal level of security for all
our users wherever they are in
the world
we hear a lot i want pl  us
security in germany
i want more security in the united states
i want to protect is given to me here the goal
of a global supplier is that where
your employees are or
where your family is where it is where you are
be wherever you are
yourself we aim to provide the same level
of security everywhere and this is
something to keep in mind when
trying to interpret why google
takes certain positions on
data location left or
right  of the planet
the last message
at the security level before pivoting on
the more regulatory and legal issues
it is the level of control that google
specifically it is
something quite specific to google this has
managed to keep over the entirety of  the
technology stack because of the size
at which google operates we
are able to fabricate a lot
of the infrastructure we
operate on at all nests at all
layers of the  stack therefore from google and
at any time of at any time of
the year one of the biggest one of the five
biggest server manufacturers in the
world for its own needs
the design of the chips that run on the
on the servers the assembly of the
servers  themselves the customization
of the pricing systems that
run the servers the
network layer that I spoke about the fiber
that we put in place ourselves
through all the layers of the stack
we have kept an
extremely important homogeneity that we  allows us
to detect incidents relatively
faster than an operator who depends
on a large number of more
commercial suppliers and to resolve or
address incidents relatively faster than
if we had to depend on
third-party suppliers, so in this time
when  the regulator requires
very short notification times where you need
to be informed without delay it is
an important advantage that a platform
so h  omogene helped deliver little so
i told you these discussions can
go on for weeks
if we have published a
white paper that goes into detail
on each of the security components
across the layers of the stack you
do a research on a
security white infrastructure  paper you
will find about thirty pages with
several paragraphs each describing
each of these bricks
what is important is that you
will find in this matrix three
major types of progress and three major
types of technological advances
the first type will be things  that
we are unique in making
things like this chip, this tpm chip
which equips all our servers and which
allows us to ensure a rite of trust on
each of the machines and to ensure that
our running on its servers only code
which has  the right to be executed is one
of the examples the fact I
also talked about the dark fiber networks
so those are the things that we  We
are the only ones to achieve the second
major category is going to be the category
of advances that other operators
also achieve, for example
registration, but in which we are
particularly demanding and on which
we differentiate ourselves by the intensity
in which we
we know these exercises to spend
a few seconds on under
the registration all
cloud operators today
offer registration
google offers you the default it is
impossible to charge to give it on
the infrastructure of  google without it
being encrypted in transit and at rest
you have several choices you
can decide to trust us
with the management of the
registration keys you can decide to
manage yourself registration decree where
you can decide to  give us your
registration keys that we will manage for
you but you keep them you keep
your own book you have your own key
in cription  in hand we have
no way we have no access to
give it so thirty seconds on how
it goes imagine you
writing a document on google cloud
whether it's an email or a dock
even before this document  either shared
the document will be divided into pieces
which will be instantly replicated
several times within the same
computing center and through several
computing centers probably distributed in
different geographical regions of the
world this is how we
achieve that we  let's aim for this
enveloping week goal of 0 0
it's myriad piece of
information a few kilos baitha a few
megabyte maximum of two sizes are
each encrypted with their own key
in cription the registration key and
yesterday relatives of the piece of the piece
of information and all of this is distributed
through the infrastructure each of its
keys each of them that one of its
registration keys pardon is itself
in  developed in encrypted itself because
it is called one that is a young club
that try kingston that they are
stored in a system called kms that
spread across the world through
many thousands of machines in our
computing centers and all access  at the
docks ms is controlled by access
control list is lobed and therefore
whatever type of information
you want to access it is
necessary to go through the ms leave
a
record that you have made a request
to access the  information this is
valid for two axes and human this
is valid to excesses machine is therefore
this one voice the kind of information
that we share now to
explain to the various regulators
how we can protect the data
and how we can ensure that
we keep a  trace of misaligned
accesses give it the third type of
development that you will find
in this matrix are the things
that google does that  in my opinion as we
say in English move denisot
really move the
security ecosystem towards a more favorable situation
obviously I have left my
security keys in my bag
since 2013
all google employees use a
hardware token a security key  which
allows us to provide a second factor
of cryptographic authentication
the use of the second factor is
a good practice which is highly
recommended
I ask you highly recommended
but which nevertheless in
many implementations today still has
very obvious weaknesses in particular
that the use of these codes can
be captured or the origin of the system
in which you want to log in
can also be exported and therefore there are
many situations in which
the usefulness or effectiveness of the
second factors can be put  in
danger
google has participated since 2013
at the beginning of 2013 in the realization of a new
standard within a large gra  nde
alliance called the flaw of
ideal hotlines 200 companies have joined this
effort paypal microsoft is now a
member to achieve
a new standard which equips its keys
and which allows us to protect our
users as well as all
consumers if you are users
gmail today you can equip
your gmail account with one of its keys
and defend them very effectively against the
main risk online today
which is phishing or the reuse
of your login and your password
thanks to these cryptographic keys  a
certain number of large
French security groups are also
members of this alliance
you will find companies like
vasco gemalto which collaborated in
the development of this standard and that it
is now something which
is spreading more and more and of which you
will benefit if you use this genre
this genre of our platform facebook
dropbox github have also adopted the
standard do  nc it's something
now that's spreading here I
want to close
the security part now
and maybe pivot in the
last twenty minutes on the more
sensitive more delicate part
we'll say about trust and how
we can help you  to build the
confidence necessary to migrate your
information on these infrastructures the
first thing that is always useful
to repeat
regardless of your familiarity or that
of your interlocutor in these
discussions
is to remember that when you
engage in a contractual relationship
with any cloud provider
you are
contractually defined as the
data controller and the cloud provider is
contractually defined as
the data processor this is the
cornerstone of all
online privacy data protection legislation this is the
cornerstone of gdp m is
what all
cloud provider contracts begin with  including
that of google
what does that mean as a
data teacher as
a step processor we do not have the
right to use your information for
any purpose other than to deliver the
service for which you have paid very
clearly in the case of google
because it is necessary given the the
discussions that have taken place in previous years
it is very clear that it is therefore against
currently impossible for us
to use  your data for advertising purposes
or even for the purpose
of improving the service that
you may continue to
use but this is contractually
impossible so this is something
that is absolutely established and that you
really have to keep in mind  because in
general the more your interlocutor will be
removed from the discussion
- he will perceive these differences in these
differences between the world of
consumers and the professional world
it is a fact that in  the
consumer world when you use these
tools for free google
remains partly data controllers and
therefore the debate is quite different
in this situation if what
interests us the limits are very clear
your legal teams during the
discussions will be at the  looking for
very specific paragraphs and statements
in contracts they will look for a
very clear statement in terms of this co
for processing
this is what we just covered so
to what extent can we use
data
we can only use data
for you  deliver the service for
which you have paid
they will look for very
precise statements very precise commitments in
terms of intellectual property a
debate which has grown considerably in
recent months this is the subject of
portability a large number of companies
today  today that we are approaching are
large companies that all of a
sudden we take the potential of  u cloud
the minimal cost that represents in the medium
term in fact the to amass so much
data in the cloud
and therefore when this project when it is
projected on scenarios of 4 to 5 years
two exit scenarios in four to
five years possibly it
realize that we are going to discuss tens of
petabytes of data okay there are
real discussions to be seen at the
downright logistical level on how are things going
how is this going to happen
google is committed to providing you with this
data  to allow you to export this
data free of charge in free formats
but also undertakes to
provide you with support to ensure that
you can get away with this
data the subject of data erasure
and has always been very important
and  particularly complex for a
public cloud provider how
can we give you the
absolute guarantee that the data which is
replicated dozens of times
through the infrastructure
whether for the infra
registration structure that I described
or cache memories that
allow you to access information
very quickly when your employees
are traveling around the world
fortunately these are debates that have
been initiated for a long time  for
google and these are commitments that
we were already giving three or
four years ago and which therefore have
not been given a name not been such an issue for us
recently but so you will find this
commitment in your contracts the
notification commitments very  at heart
for regulators today the
duty to notify you without delay of
any incident which would relate to your
information the audits
how can you be sure that
we are doing all that we claim to
do it is a problem for a
supplier of  cloud which has millions
of customers
never any none of the
legal teams i hire them
glad to hear that eventually
we could if we have six
mi  llions of customers
5 million 900 thousand 999 others will
visit our computing centers to
check that everything is going as they
want
it is not a situation that
we can afford
and therefore we had to find
mechanisms that allow us to
guarantee data security while
satisfying regulators and we
ensure that you can verify
that we do what we
say we do guarantee
security commitments so you signed up
today for a certain
security guarantee that tells you that in  5 10
years we will have the same capacities we
will have the same certifications this must
be contractually guaranteed and you will
find this kind of guarantee in
your contract this
is a very important position, especially in
france where the concept of the
security insurance plan is very  developed
and therefore many large
companies submit to their
cloud providers specifications
of twenty  groin
sometimes 80 pages of
contractual security commitments which is
technically impossible for a
cloud platform accepted here for 6
million customers we are beginning to
accept the contractual
security commitments of all customers
we are unable to maintain consistency
in our  contractual commitment and
therefore the way we proceed
is to take your security assurance plans
and then do a
control-by-control mapping on the
granular security audit reports
that are available to you and in this
way we bring back your
security assurance plans on each of its
contractual commitments such
as audit reports are guaranteed
contractually
you have in fact there the guarantee
that we will maintain the security that
you require in the security assurance plans
the subcontractors are a
question  important
you must have the regulator asks
today that you can have a
known opinion  r what are the subcontractors
that we that we use in the
chain it is something that is put
in place now and the last
most important point for which I kept
ten whole minutes international transfers
very important to be able to
talk about it before  so we talked about auditing
like all cloud platforms
google is certified on the major
security standards computing cloud
computing and management of private data
on a cloud platform the major
soc certifications that allow us to
deliver extremely granular reports,
so in particular the  soc 2 which
is a 220-page report with
several controls per page which is
suddenly available to you and which
is therefore one of the main tools to
allow us to give you access to
a detailed analysis of
which security controls
we submit to  and to which we undertake
that we undertake to preserve
throughout our of our  he
contractual relationship must be explained I
want to stop at a second source badge
here which may not seem relevant since
it is an American badge it is the badge that
causes drama which allows us all
allows google to deliver these services  to the
american federal agencies of defense
or whatever all the cloud providers
today are very proud to be able to
have this badge and to be able to show that
we meet the
security requirements of this kind of two customers
google is the only platform
today that has achieved  this
certification for its entire
platform the other operators
today have this certification
but for dedicated platforms that
have been built specifically to serve
its customers there today
when theresa may use our
platform
these data are sometimes in the united states
sometimes  in holland in belgium
maybe sometimes is because
the entire platform has received a
health this certification it  there is
no split in the platform we
have started the process of
submitting ourselves to
local certification bodies so in the case of the
client that i only recently put so a
uk certification and we are
we have a prioritization system
that we  makes it possible to prioritize in fact
these different sedif and its different
projects the fact is that in 100% of
cases the questions that are asked of us
are in fact a remix of the
global certifications and therefore we want to make
sure that we go for the time
it takes  and not too much to have
each certification according to the
needs of each market
it is for this reason that
initiatives like the gpr are in fact
relatively welcome an initiative
which unifies the regulatory landscape in
a region as important
as europe and which  makes the teams that
makes the debate extremely important
leads it the fate of either the
compliance or technical sphere and brings it into
the sphere  at the level of the 7g dpr board is
something that in fact
relatively simplifies the life of cloud providers
today we had started
several years ago already because of our
constant interaction with the
European regulatory bodies, in
particular the modifications to our
platform to anticipate the  requests
which has allowed us during the year
already to announce that we would
comply with the expectations of the gdp
r and if you are subscribed to our
twitterfeed or other social page
you may have even received the
mail directly on Friday you should
have received the announcement that you
now have at your disposal the
new contracts which reflect the
requirements of the gdp air in a
contractual commitment is therefore
today there is no longer any
doubt to have  on the compliance of
your state processor with respect to the
regulator to the European regulator
the big question that remains all the
time is what about the  requirements
of the gdp air and data localization
in europe
the only way that i finally found
to facilitate the discussions is to discuss it
more and to just take a
screenshot of the article 46 of the gdp air
of the  show and let it read the
gdp m
contrary to discussions in the
public square has actually grown
over previous legislation
the options you have to
enable international data transfers
outside of europe the
controller to the processor can transfer
data  personal information to a
third country
if the against their processors has put in
place adequate defenses six options
, three of which are offered by all
service providers today the privacy
schild which will have its future which is
debated if you are a specialist you
know that  there are great discussions
on the validity of the project file but
especially the standard contractual clauses
which are clauses of the
models don  t the model was proposed
by the European privacy defense authorities
who proposed these
models, we will say relatively
practically imposed on the service provider
and all the cloud service providers
today include the
standard contractual clauses in their
contractual offer, which makes them  allows you
to operate from hand to hand in a
completely compliant way
international data transfers these are the
clauses that allow you
to use a public cloud
regardless of location claims
to give 13 in europe in
europe all cloud platforms
today sees data flows
circulating on the left or on the right active
directory is not geolocable
active directory and the repository
of state predictions and is not geolocated
the reason why you can
use active directory one day
is  because you have signed
standard contractual clauses which
allow you to use support in
full  equality
if you want to use
load balancing functionalities which
are one of the main tools in defense
against danaïdes of service attacks
regardless of the cloud provider
you will sign standard contractual clauses
if you want to use the county of
books network to reduce the  latency
you will sign
standard contractual clauses these are the
clauses that allow you
to use a cloud service in full
compliance with the data and which
circulate outside europe
regardless of the
geolocation discussions given to trust or not that
c  it is a myth what i know i
always try to well known that
google standard contractual clauses
were proposed to different
european authorities during summer 2016
the process was long but in february
we received the  approval of all
European privacy authorities
including the cnil which has a
package that was part of this process  us
there under the direction of the authority of
hamburg and spanish as well
as irish is therefore this positive opinion
and binding as we say in english i
believe that constraining is perhaps
exaggerated in french no constraint
really but in any case it  is not
possible for a
European privacy defense authority to reconsider
this opinion which has been given and therefore
the validity of our
standard contractual clauses added in the long
term allow you to use these
platforms in full compliance with the
debates around  of the localization of the
deal and continues and are relatively
intense for the moment since February I
will participate in a workshop in
brussels where the european regulator is
worried about the increase in
local measures which aimed to keep
from giving it in the countries  France has a
very characteristic example
but in fact about fifty measures
exist in Europe where each country tries
to keep a little bit of indulging in
p  ays the European regulator is
basically worried to sum up
the official who is moreover a
Frenchman who is leading this initiative we
have beaten we have worked for 50 years to
build a unified space of free flow
pipeau and then the meaning of the  the economy that
she gave today we will keep it
within the countries it is
simply nonsense they worked for a year
and in September on September 19 they
published what this bill proposes
which flees it  it is afloat draf
the water which will therefore basically commit all
the member states which still have these
measures to go and review them and give them
twelve months for the east to be justified or
to make them disappear
so that gives you an idea of
dynamic in progress today
I think that all over the world
and eight months or 10 months ago we
could ask ourselves questions about what
direction the world was going to take a
certain number of elections took place in
the world which clearly  gave the
direction  rs an opening and a stop
to this treatment isolationist trend
so here are a few minutes
the last message on the age dpr
maybe it's that the gdp m you
have a concern about us in
what how is your
processor is in line with the dpr age but
the concern
it is really important for you
that is to say that the regulator it will
ask you to change your
culture to change your processes
possibly to see how
technology can help you to equip
different entities in your in your
organizations to enable and
allow your different operations
to change the way it handles
personal data the challenges
are immense a number of these
tasks are taken over by your
cloud provider depending in
fact on how you
decide  to go up on the cloud but
your public cloud provider
will support a certain number of 7
hours it's technical or regulatory  but a
certain number will remain within your
purview the message that I want to
share with you is that there are a large
number of these solutions available in
the cloud portfolio which can
greatly help I will simply name
the data loss prevention technology
which  has existed for a long time in
the business world and which
allowed your teams to avoid
intentional or unintentional exfiltration of
sensitive documents is today
something that is made available
by google in the form of a and
looting  and which will allow you to
scan the terabyte petabyte
of information that you have and
to identify the personal data
possibly even in real time, that is
to say that you will be able to equip
a simulation of an Andean chat session
sales manager  and his
client and when the client will
return personal
data the data will be identified as real
will be able to be combined with a
special bucket  specific which will be subject to a
specific policy which will possibly be subject to
very very specific security measures I want to end
with a conclusion message in
all cases the decisions the decision-
makers face an important decision
mounted on the cloud or not  mount this
or that data on the cloud or not
i'm trying to communicate this advice
tried to divide your decision-
making process into four distinct layers the
first is to do a
purely technical assessment of your decision or is
your data going to be the
safer on your own infrastructure or
on a globalized infrastructure in
atomized encrypted where the information is
atomized around the world it's up
to you to do the assessment we
are quite sure and last twelve months
spent in europe
I have not yet seen  a case where a
client comes to a contrary decision
on that week the second
separate assessment could be
legal what is the law
really ask the gdp is very clear
ask your legal teams ask for
advice the legal discussions are
changing very quickly
and this legal discussion is
simplifying and apparently we could
end up very quickly in a situation where these
situations these constraints
disappear
the true level that remains it  is the
political level a number of countries are
passing laws today
that require give and stay in countries
russia
in 2015 china in june 2017
if you are operating in these countries you need to
make sure you have the right
ones  good commitments good
capacity with your cloud provider
to be sure you can operate in these
countries mind your as they say in
English you realize that the reasons
why a country wants to keep
data within its borders are
rarely for better  protect them
the third the third reason
is cultural it extremely
valid and it can be the ra  ison for
which it is impossible for you
today to mount certain types of
data on the cloud
you have unions you have
parents of students you have emotions
it is a fact
what is important is to be well
aware
I didn't say powell you have to be
aware if you decide to do a
technical trade off or a security trade off
for cultural reasons
after the decision is
actually quite here the constraints are there and
you have to navigate but there you go  I
often see that there is confusion between
these different decision-making regimes and
clarifying it in this way can help
here I hope it was useful I
am happy to have guests grégoire on the
podium who will share
more information with  some of
our customers in france
[applause]
so i invite to join me on the
stage thomas hashage from dailymotion
christophe from bankruptcy at amadeus and
françois nguyen from la redoute so
first of all thanks to t  All three of you
testified this morning, which doesn't take away the idea,
it's that we can dig a little deeper into what
you presented to us in a
little more intimate way and so if it has to be,
François,
let's start with you
First of all, can you perhaps represent us
very quickly at La Redoubt and above all
what you do there?
is
attached to the presidency of redoubt
is in fact part
of redoubt's transformation strategy data is
a pillar here it is one of the seven
strategy clichés of redoubt
so I came here I see there animating this
subject data at redoubt
excellent thank you then so can you
now detail the
issues that you have managed to raise
thanks to the big data solution then well it
is absolutely necessary that you speak to us about
biti inherits even caused a sensation
so you can imagine the situation one  little
in 2014
it took tr  to form this
society a lot this society is a lot
it's transformed by these
information systems and so we
actually found ourselves with a
completely new environment and suddenly there was a
lot of data but which people
ultimately couldn't access  really is
therefore the first challenge for me it
was really to be able to finally
capture this date rare
in all the information systems
so there we must be about 90 95%
and that was the first
technical challenge  it was that here we wanted to
open this and quickly
we wanted it to be without limit in
quotes and so that was another
our first
the first objective and after good it's
good to collect the data but it's a
moment  you are not finally able
to restore it giving access sas does not make
much sense it is therefore the second
challenge for us and also
through finally the google tools
it was to be able to restore the access  ess to
people when I didn't say for
example during the plenary today
there are 200 people who access
google bikkuri here and that's actually me
I had people who said but
never I brake sql queries in my
life never  it's not my job it's
my profession
and all that and finally the fact
of arriving in a place where there was
all the data of the theater eyelash company
accessible will have finally made
him want to ask you the request is
in it he finally found things
that I had been looking for for quite a
long time and that they did not have access to
and that what I also did not tell
is that we have a training session
on bekoe rice every fortnight  we have
we have a lot of success in relation to that
and me I it's a surprise for me
too because I didn't think
that people could go
elsewhere the joke
in fact in the north here you have
all the generations in the  within the
redoubt you have people  who have been
working at renault for more than
30 years here and so here I have a lady
one day here, a bit of a certain age
who comes to see me and tells me that it
seems that there are deadlines given to
me  interested in beat kirin how I
picked access so that struck
me because here I suddenly said to myself
but maybe we had finally made
a little cultural revolution and so
that was the little line
of humor
and then the last point which is also not
negligible is the profiles there were
n't really any developers at the
dread is the fact of returning and a
platform
that is always marked there developers
were all that it was  that too the
third big change concerning
excellent great thank you very much
can you tell us
now about the next
uses or the thoughts you have in
progress on the use of public cloud eggs
so here today we  is very
once a day  95% of the company's data,
we have a bit of a chance,
it's just that in the transformation plan,
everything goes through usb and
so here's our next big step,
it's real time here and we
we already have a few we're going to say goodies
that we're having fun for months there but
we're going to go much
further than that and so the idea really
is to replenish the
operational systems the website the apps
with  real-time data retired
so that's the first against
chalon there's a second challenge that
we started it's really
to exploit all the APIs that we
let go of looking for at google we  turns
it's always a bit pompous the second
of artificial intelligence but here it is
in the next I said that in the
next mobile apps of
redoubt voice search
that now represents a large
volume will be passed in the mobile app
of  the redoubt and in the end we
passed it through the asp  i chappy hayden from
google we weren't going to have the time to
finally redevelop something
that would fit someone from hyper france
is really here we are happier more
real time more finally return to
nuuk lignon and that here is me my
goal c  is that it's in this
second stage of the transformation
it's that it can now be seen by our
customers here are three listens thank you
very much françois false testimony
christophe same same question to
start can you give us
a quick little
amadeus theta ii and then what you do at
home
yeah well listen it's once again
thank you for the invitation so i'm
amadeus director of development in
charge of some of the
airlines so i take care of  all
that is management of their skis duel of
their inventory of the situation of the
seats in the planes and then even
when a plane is late or canceled
unfortunately I take care of the
software for you  look for the
best possible seats in the
planes according to what so it is a
fairly wide perimeter and what is very
interesting very complicated is that we
have one hundred and forty airlines on
the system of all the big
Europeans like british airways
lufthansa air france  but also
Americans like southwest
Asians like singapore airlines
korean air so it's really very
diversified and which is interesting
because we see different cultures
in terms of the use of travel
spoken by the inhabitants of these
different countries
so  so that's also interesting
from a cultural point of view
and then of course the
platform has to be there it runs 24 hours a
day 7 days a week so that if we have
peaks in traffic we are able
to absorb it  is therefore full of questions
to ask around that great thank you and
the device can you re-
detail the issues that you have
addressed thanks to our key solutions  oud
platform and then maybe the
difficulties or the researchers that you
encountered in the deployment
but if we still have trouble with our
soldiers then as I
said earlier really the problem
was  a problem of volumetry that we
wanted to address
because
the growth of the search
for prices and availability is really
exponential in the system and at the
same time a problem
of response time so that's why we
brought  availability calculation applications
in the cloud closer
to consumers at the end of the summer
chanel distribution
the challenge was technical of course
because we had to find how
to port applications which were
applications back india c++ micro service
is sure of the clad  very modern
so that's why we invested so
personally with our engineers in
the development of the qu berne
ites project to be sure that no more claude
was going well match and  with the project
is so all this technical challenge
seems like it was the easy part actually
because we had the right engineers
the right 27 we had the support of the
engineers from google the engineers from the
other open source communities so that
was it  was pretty cool but it goes
beyond that in fact it's really
also a complete transformation of the
way of working
in the company we need to have
developments that are much more
agile so we really transformed our
developments which was completely
waterfall  in completely agile we
even have some places so not for this
project but some places where
we even do agile with the client
as product owner so that's
really really a change of
mindset that we have to support and then
well  of course there is the whole operational part the
operational part
running our applications on a
public cloud whereas we were used
to having our own infrastructure  are our
own that we still have our
own infrastructures,
we still have to adapt to a model where or
well everything is defined as a rescuer and so we
had to go a step further,
we grouped together the developments and the
operations  we started to
build really box teams and
inevitably there were a few
cultural changes in
the way of doing things because we had to
stop a culture where you have to
automate all the time automated
versus a more legacy culture  or
operations rather
tended to do things a
little more repetitive little by little so there really is the
culture of automation and then behind
all that it is also a change
of organization so to accompany the
change to also transform  the
profession of people from before towards the profession
of people standing hands of father john
technique
then you go you will have all on
it and then maybe suddenly the
next uses or the next of the
stages that you have imagined or planned
around the use of public cloud
absolutely sure everything that I would have
transformational we have in capital on what
we have done we now times on
the rest of the organizations and even on
on  things that won't move in
the cloud since we also see the
great benefits of it so that's rather
it's rather in a good
capitalist direction on it and then after
now
we're starting to look beyond the clad
uses that  we currently have
what is
massive data management since we
have so much data that aggregates
on travelers on the different
airline networks
how can we capitalize on all
this information to offer an
experience to travelers  more
personalized
for the time being their way for example a
description it the passengers will not
want some preferred to have
an aircraft immediately to leave
on the flight according to some  will
prefer that we follow without their knowledge to have
a night in a hotel and then they calmly leave the
next day so these are
things we try to learn in order to be
able to give
the best user experiences so it's
really to capitalize  on everything that is
personalization and our data to be
able to do so had to do machine learning
of big data and so on me so
I think that this is one of the major
movements on which we are
now working beyond our
massive investment in the clad nothing at all
quebec costs thank you very much and so
thomas
so is that the same can you
tell us a bit about dailymotion, in
particular about your launch not
very long ago
and then and then about what you do there
webb listens to dailymotion very well
indeed  so it's a
video distribution platform
so we have the data we've organized
into 4 big four big teams we
really have a team that manages
the infrastructure all the time  your secular
finally I'm talking about infrastructure me we
weren't in it because we're far from
it but who really takes care
of ingest transforming and serving
give it to all of our users
we have an analytics team that  will
really help the business to exploit
and understand this data and we have two
real data product teams
who will make data products
for
users recommendation search
understanding of videos and a
data product team who will do
products for the platform the
detection of fraud
the detection of that of all who operated
etc to ensure that we are in an
environment which is kiev
here we are and we have made
absolutely dazzling progress over the past year
where we have not  there was almost nothing in fact
the team was doing two people
when I arrived and there we put everything
in place
we still have a lot of work to do
but we could never have done it
without Arabia ten  zer was totally
impossible
remains that you can tell us
perhaps a little precisely this process
there how it has risen in place
during the year which has just passed
and the way in which you use a
solution in fact it  is funny because
I came from criteo before coming
from dailymotion beautiful beautiful
box and criteo one of
the most impressive premise clusters in
europe if not world 1 since they
are running a hadoop cluster with it at
the time  more than 25000 ne of which 5000
was dedicated to the analytics with which
we worked france and a colorist
covered 5000 the super impressive
magnificent team
finally god durrrr dwan and
yet when we launched a run
I write the robin pronounce the [ __ ]
and then we had  the answer often
half an hour an hour later I came
back to dailymotion I saw big korea
and Thursday morning but it's incredible
what we have in five seconds
it has completely changed  way of
working it completely changed my
approach and ayew sol I'm ok it's
good we have to work and there's
so much work to do we have
so much transformation to do that
we can't  make it possible to invest in
the infrastructure
I remember precisely my arrival of the
critical projects it was the migration
of the hadoop cluster we had
planned in a cheerful spirit at all you put away the
machines we pack up the budgets have
over that and we are excessively
happy today we use a very very
wide range of products to
offer you I spoke about it earlier in
plenary we use pop sum for the
for the message broker we use
dataflow for real-time processing
we use a lot  by chris
botti fabulous and we do a lot of
machine learning too with with with
tender flou and claude hamel all our
neural network models are trained
with their domains
and that helps us a lot for the
development what is interesting
is that this cloud spirit came a
little bit through the dailymotion game data and
today we see that it is in the process
of this year through the other
services
the deployment and management teams
points of presence are starting to
use google clouds
not yet to distribute video
as such but at least to respond
to applications and to serve the front so
you are to be used in my super nes
and we are basing the continuation of our
distribution on  the google cloud so
little by little the culture in the process of
encrypting the super thank you very much
in the new uses that you
are trying or experimenting with you were
talking about machine learning in particular there
are other subjects that you look at where
is  what you can tell us a little
more about this one it's mostly it's
mostly this one we expected I think
we're not we just haven't
reached the end of what we can make
work  them  r let's say we're
really starting but I think
cloud continuity is now outside of
our team have done more than us we
're completely on the move and
[Music]
and we've got it we've got it very well  seen with the
with the recent deployments with so
he bern is used here to
serve all new replicas and
are dailymotion and they are
more and more convinced of it they see that it
works well recently there has been a
destruction of services in full  night
no one realized it
all went away all us were served
instantly from asia and we got
up one morning he holds a speech of
service and a bit of soul that
woke up  he didn't even have the
survival time ex already that it was already back on
track what and so these examples
reinforce them in the use of this
product there you lose here it can be
thank you very much thank you all
three for your interventions and your
testimonies  ges it is I think the best
way to realize our
solutions
when our customers tell us about them